[Music]
[Music]
nature is lawful
as far as we can tell
the universe and all that it is made of
changes from moment to moment according
to fixed
unchangeable
immutable patterns and those patterns as
it tested to by a couple hundred years
of observation and calculation can be
expressed
in the language of mathematics indeed
it is
this
mathematics right here
that describes the fundamental equations
of the world within this mathematics we
have a description of einstein's general
theory of relativity the standard model
of particle physics equations that
describe how the force of gravity works
how the electromagnetic force works
how the strong and weak nuclear forces
work and all the particles of matter
on which
those
forces
act
this
takes us tantalizingly close to the
reductionist dream of a theory of
everything at least
at the level of the fundamental laws
and
the fundamental
ingredients
now i can well imagine that if you're
not familiar with all of this you may
still be wondering
what does that really mean i mean how do
these symbols describe
these
particles
well the answer is that we can use
mathematics to delineate the
configuration of the particles we can
use numbers to describe where the
particles are and how the particles are
moving or in the quantum mechanical
language the probabilities for those
qualities and
we can use mathematics to describe the
intrinsic features of those particles
right i mean the the mass of a particle
that's a number
the amount of electric charge that a
particle has that's a number the spin
of a particle that is a number two and
here's the thing
we can take
all of these numbers as input and use
the mathematical equations to produce as
output another set of numbers
that delineates the configuration and
the properties of those particles at any
subsequent moment in time that is how
mathematics can encapsulate the patterns
followed by all of nature's ingredients
the fundamental ingredients of
everything
as they evolve from moment to moment
through time
now this is a
remarkable achievement showing how
mathematics can describe the universe at
a fundamental
level but even long before
these modern developments mathematics
had already shown itself
capable of giving deep insights into the
workings of the world i mean even even
20 centuries ago the greek mathematician
eratosthenes
he was able to use mathematics
to figure out the size
of the earth and the pattern that
eratosthenes used is a is a very simple
one he noted that the difference in the
lengths of
shadows cast by two identical sticks at
a given separation from one another the
difference in the lengths of those
shadows depends
sensitively
on the size
of the earth right i mean
earth gets bigger and bigger
the less and less the difference between
those lengths become
and so by actually measuring the
difference in the lengths of the shadows
cast by two identical sticks
actually calculating the angle of those
shadows but it's all the same in the end
eratosthenes was able to figure out
the size of planet earth that's a a
remarkable demonstration of the capacity
of mathematics to
reveal qualities of the world that are
seemingly beyond our ability
to measure
now
some centuries later
isaac newton
took this idea of using math to describe
reality took it to
an extraordinarily new level through
careful observation
and thought about how objects move
newton was able to discern patterns in
the motion of those objects perhaps most
famously he found that if you if you
push
on an object if you exert a force on it
that object
it will speed up it will accelerate
and
that acceleration is proportional to the
force and inversely proportional to the
mass of the object embodied
in newton's famous second law
of motion now newton also found that if
you have two objects
out there in space the pull of one
object on the other through gravity will
be proportional to the product of their
masses
and inversely proportional to the square
of their separation
that's newton's famous
universal law
of gravity
and these equations are central to what
came to be called
classical
physics and
what a
what a stunning
picture of the world classical physics
gives us
if you provide me with the positions and
the velocities of all objects all
particles we can use
the mathematics of classical physics to
predict the configuration the motion and
positions of those particles tomorrow
the next day the next year the next
millennia or a billion millennia into
the future newton kind of
likened the universe to a
grand
cosmic
clockwork you you wind up the universe
and the mathematical laws then dictate
how the universe ticks
forward
in time whether it's a
turning cog or
a spinning wheel or a tumbling raindrop
or a hurtling rock or the orbiting moon
newton's
mathematics gave us an astoundingly
precise
description
of
the natural world and
on occasion when newton's mathematics
seemed to be a little bit off
oftentimes it was actually just pointing
toward some hidden feature of reality
back in the
mid 19th century astronomers
noticed that the orbit of uranus had
some irregularities that that could not
be accounted for
using
newton's universal law of gravity but
they also found that those
irregularities they had their own
inner pattern a pattern that could be
explained
if one imagined that there was a
hidden
hitherto unknown planet out there in
space
whose gravity was tugging
on
the planet uranus and indeed
the astronomers were able to calculate
where that hidden planet should be
and on a september night
1846
when those astronomers turned their
telescopes to the predicted position in
the night sky
they discovered
the planet
neptune a remarkable example
of mathematics revealing
qualities
of the world
but
even newton's ideas newton's mathematics
was heading toward its own reckoning
early years of the 20th century
scientists begin to
examine with precision
the microscopic realm molecules atoms
subatomic particles and in that domain
the newtonian ideas however successful
they had been in describing motion in
the skies and motion here on earth the
newtonian ideas were giving predictions
that were completely at odds with the
data
remarkably it just took a single
generation of scientists
to overhaul
newton's classical ideas giving us the
quantum mechanical description of the
world a description in which the
universe evolves according to
a mathematically precise game of chance
with the mathematics
given by
a new quantum equation schrodinger's
equation an equation that makes its own
astounding predictions about the micro
world it tells us that
particles should be able to penetrate
through seemingly impermeable
barriers it tells us that
two distant particles can somehow
influence each other instantaneously
across any distance
the math even predicts
the existence of particles that had
never been seen before
and all of those
predictions have now been borne out by a
mountain of experimental data
the quantum mathematics is
jaw-droppingly
precise we can even use it to describe
certain
properties of particles such as the
magnetic properties of electrons and the
mathematics makes predictions to many
decimal places and when we do the
experiment the measured values agree
with the theoretical prediction
digit
by digit
by digit
by digit
a clear demonstration
of the power
of mathematics to describe
reality
even right here right
we can see
the work of quantum mechanics
in the fact that in this domain right
now this is what this room actually
looks like
but using the power of quantum mechanics
which has given rise to the powerful
computational tools of the digital
revolution we can take this room
and make it look
like this
[Music]
now all these
successes of the mathematical
description of the world raise a number
of
difficult and thorny questions right i
mean is
is mathematics invented
or is it discovered that is is is math a
product of the human imagination is
matha
a language that we have developed over
the course of many centuries for the
express purpose of articulating the
patterns that we encounter in the
natural world
in a sense then is
our sense that the world is mathematical
nothing but the fact that we have
developed a particular tool a kind of
mathematical hammer that makes
everything look
like a mathematical nail
or to the contrary
is math
discovered is math
out there independent of of our
understanding independent
of us is it deeply woven into the very
fibers of reality and if that is the
case
is it still possible that there's
something
beyond
mathematics perhaps there's something
beyond math that can illuminate
the
most ephemeral and precious qualities
of human experience like like
consciousness and the kinds of things
that conscious beings contemplate
like value
ethics morality purpose
and meaning
these are the kinds of
questions that we're going to be talking
about here
today
they're difficult
they're contentious there is no
consensus on the answers to these
questions but these questions will
surely drive
an energetic vibrant conversation on the
relationship between mathematics
and reality
all right let's get to it
[Music]
so with that let me now bring in
david albert is the frederick e
woodbridge professor of philosophy at
columbia university and a physicist who
explores the foundations of quantum
mechanics world-renowned for his
insights into philosophical questions
about the nature of space time and other
problems of modern physics
welcome david albert
next is sheldon goldstein a professor of
mathematics and physics and philosophy
at rutgers university he studies the
foundations of quantum theory
probability theory and statistical
mechanics
the notion of increasing entropy and the
arrow of time welcome shelley
next is sylvia jonas who is a professor
of philosophy at munich center for
mathematical philosophy with a phd in
philosophy from humboldt university in
berlin
she studies epistemology the philosophy
of mathematics science metaphysics meta
ethics philosophy of religion and
aesthetics
welcome sylvia
finally last but absolutely not least is
max tegmark a physicist cosmologist and
machine learning researcher at the
massachusetts institute of technology
and a co-founder of the future of life
institute
welcome max so thanks to all of you for
joining us for this conversation about
these
issues that really people have
thought about struggled with come to a
whole wide variety of perspectives on
over the course of of truly hundreds if
not thousands of years in one form or
another
and i thought i'd begin
to set the stage with giving some quotes
from
famous accomplished renowned
mathematicians in the past
who weighed in with their own views on
some of the questions we'll be talking
about just to sort of
set a bit of a backdrop of how the field
has viewed these questions so let me
start with chronicler god made the
integers
all the rest is the work of man famous
mathematician g h hardy i believe that
mathematical reality lies outside us
that our function is to discover or
observe it andrew wiles more in our
generation to tell you the truth i don't
think i know a mathematician who doesn't
think that math is discovered
and wouldn't be right to end this list
of quotes without bringing in albert
einstein himself
who once said as far as the laws of
mathematics refer to reality they are
not certain and as far as they are
certain
they do not refer to reality
all right so those are a whole variety
of perspectives on the invention
question the discovery question whether
it's out there whether it is something
mathematics emerges from
the machinations of the human mind but
let's begin
at the beginning if you will by just
having a little bit
of the history of mathematics i mean
oftentimes
when we learn mathematics in the
classroom
at least when i learned in the classroom
it was just presented as his body of
knowledge
there is no sense that this knowledge
even emerged from the struggles
of of humans thinking about things but
of course mathematics as we understand
it as we practice it as we use it is a
body of insight that emerged over a long
course of history so sylvia can you just
give us
a thumbnail sketch of the history of
mathematical development sure yes there
are four
stages in the unfolding of mathematical
history
the beginning was in ancient mesopotamia
and babylon a tool that was used for
example calculating lunar calendars or
measuring plots of lands in order to
determine who owns what
in ancient greece
mathematics became something quite
different
the ancient greeks associated the laws
of mathematics with something
that they consider to be
ultimate reality plato for example
thought that ultimate reality
is
not physical reality which is what we
think today but a sort of heaven of
eternal forms not only mathematical
entities
but also things like beauty justice
truth all of these with capital letters
as it were
there is this famous legend that it said
on top of his academy let no one
ignorant of geometry enter here
he believed that mathematical knowledge
was the only kind of perfect knowledge
and in order to gain knowledge about any
other thing you would first have to be
proficient in mathematics so ultimate
reality was seen to be in this platonic
heaven outside and completely different
from physical reality
jumping ahead centuries
during the time of the scientific
revolution things were completely
different
all of a sudden scientists started to
discover that our physical reality
follows mathematical laws and that we
can actually
explain
empirical phenomena using mathematical
laws
so in that sense
ultimate reality was now identified with
physical reality and mathematical and
physical reality became two sides of the
same coin they were seen as interwoven
that picture changed again in the 19th
century with the introduction of
mathematical concepts that didn't have
very straightforward relevance for our
physical world anymore
non-euclidean geometries for example
so all of a sudden mathematicians
started to feel free to explore
mathematical entities that had
no connection to the empirical world
anymore
and that caused a complete shift in the
way mathematics was seen no longer
essential part of our physical reality
but as a tool that scientists can use
but they can also discard it their
pleasure
today things have yet again changed
we're at a point where we can see that
mathematical reality and physical
reality intersect but there are two
separate realities existing
independently of one another
great so thank you for that history
shelley you know in that in that history
that sylvia just recounted
and of course in your own experience as
a philosopher a mathematician who
focuses on questions about the physical
universe do you do you see math as this
tool for describing the external reality
or do you see math as something bigger
than that in the language that sylvia
was saying
touching upon
a reality that perhaps goes beyond the
physical reality or is parallel to the
physical reality somehow separate from
the reality that's made up of tables and
chairs
yes i i mean i certainly see it as a
tool but certainly see it as something
beyond the tool
i guess for me
however hard it is for even me to
understand even though it's my view
i think that mathematical reality is the
reality we know best
the reality
that we can be most confident about
even if we have the sense that we
don't know where it is or how we could
know it given how we interact
and gain with things and gain knowledge
there's so many mysterious things about
mathematics but at the end of the day i
do think it's the thing we
know best and it's the reality which we
can have the most confidence in
and and so mathematical reality it
exists in in in human heads for sure
right so when we think about the ideas
of mathematics it amounts to something
inside of a human brain firing one way
or another thinking about a square root
thinking about a factorial thinking
about the number 17 or whatever so so
david
are we fooling ourselves
in in thinking that math is somehow
out there
touching some deeper reality when in
essence it's really just
something that is invented and lives the
only place we're certain that it lives
in the human mind
i'm not sure that i have anything
particularly deep to say about this
um and i should say to the audience
david always begins every answer that
way and he always has something deep but
anyway
i mean
there's a famous 20th century
philosopher um named quine
one of the things he's famous for is a
criterion for what we should take to be
real for what our discourse commits us
to
thinking
actually
exists
basically the idea is
if there's something that we find we
can't do science
without talking about as if it's a real
thing
then we should count it as real
and otherwise we shouldn't quine
famously thought that
that certain claims about numbers are
the kinds of things that you have to
talk about as if the numbers are real
things other people people who were very
interested in crime's criteria but
thought he might have made a misjudgment
about this particular case people
famously like hartree field for example
have tried to show that there are ways
of doing science without acting as if
numbers are are real objects um out
there in the world i think it might be
it might be useful to regard this as a
scientific question and you allow that
to guide your beliefs about what may
exist and and what may not exist and the
guide is essentially if you find
that there's a certain kind of object
whose existence you need to commit
yourself to in order to get the
scientific project done
then you ought to believe in that if not
not
so so just every when you like
are are playing with the schrodinger
equation from quantum mechanics which is
a subject that you've spent a lot of
time thinking about
uh if you're not
thinking hard about the question of
invention versus discovery
do you have a
sort of working methodology that's in
the back of your mind that views this as
a mere description of the world versus
when you write down schrodinger's
equation you're like this is the world
there are lots of physicists who like to
say it's a great mystery this question
of how mathematics applies to the world
why mathematics applies to the world why
we're so lucky as for it to be the case
that mathematics applies to the world
fraga famously says
i don't see what these people are
talking about
i can't imagine a situation in which
mathematics would fail to apply to the
world somebody says to me i have two
apples over here and i have another two
apples over here um isn't it a miracle
that the fact that mathematically
abstractly two plus two equals four
applies to these apples
i'm tempted to turn the the question on
its head it's very difficult for me to
imagine what the world would have to be
like in order for that to fail to be the
case so max
jumping off from that i know you have
very strong views on the reason why
mathematics does work in in the manner
that we've been describing we're going
to come to that later on in the
discussion but just in a more cursory
cursory way right now
math in your mind invented or discovered
discovered
so it's out there
yeah i think we
when people have
these arguments is it invented or
discovered
when people say it's invented i think
what they are often after is that the
language of mathematics is invented like
we invent
the calligraphy by which we write the
number five because in china you can
write it differently or we invent the
word for five you know which in swedish
is fem so obviously
that wasn't discovered we humans just
kind of made it up i think that's very
analogous to like if you look in the
solar system
and argue about whether the whether the
planet neptune was invented or
discovered obviously the name for it was
invented because in swedish we call it
neptunus there's a there's nothing
fundamental but the existence of neptune
i would very strongly argue is not
something we made up it's just out there
and in exactly the same way when you go
and look for mathematical objects out
there like plato as as you mentioned
brian
was really interested in these regular
shapes called platonic solids
and he could invent the name
dodecahedron for the one that's
made of 12 pentagons
he could have called it schmodecahedron
instead if he wanted
but he couldn't invent the sixth one
because it doesn't exist
just like you can't just invent another
planet in the solar system in that sense
i feel that these mathematical
structures
really are
discovered
even though we invent the language for
talking about them well let me ask the
group
do any of you allow for the possibility
that one day we're having a conversation
with some intelligent alien civilization
and they ask us okay what have you guys
been doing to try to figure out reality
and we show them our latest greatest
mathematical description of the world
and they turn to us and they kind of
roll their eyes or they sort of pat us
on the head and say we understand that
direction mathematics we try that for a
while too
but then we found that it was a dead end
and the real way for describing reality
is this
and they give us some other
description of the world or or way of
thinking about the world that's not math
it's not even disguised math it's just
something else
do you allow that as a possibility
i certainly allow it as a
possibility although i wish i could
imagine what that would be like but
probably it's important to distinguish
between
whether or not
our world has to be described
in mathematical terms that mathematics
is the
language
to express the nature of physical
reality
and whether
even if
physical reality
could best be described in other terms
there would still be mathematical
reality the validity of mathematical
reality wouldn't be diminished it
wouldn't be as
you could be an imperialist about
mathematics and say mathematics is
everything
you could be the opposite and say
mathematics is nothing
i think the reasonable view is
mathematics is something but not
everything but one of the arguments that
certainly has been put forward over a
long period of time for
why math should be viewed
as really out there
is in some sense
you know the the unreasonableness of
mathematics to quote a famous paper in
describing how things actually work in
the world so just to be a con give a
concrete example
when isaac newton was writing down the
universal law of gravity he had access
to certain observations certain data to
a certain degree of accuracy a certain
precision
and you could imagine he wrote down this
formula that was able to describe the
things at that level of accuracy but
then
as the years and decades go by our
ability to measure the world gets better
and better and shockingly newton's ideas
continue to work and that leads a sense
of okay this is some deep actual truth
of the world not just some human
description of the world but then the
counter-argument is at some point
the data becomes so
precise that newton does fail and of
course we have to bring in einstein's
description of gravity a different
equation different mathematics so then
it leads you to believe well maybe
newton's was just a provisional
description made up by a brilliant human
mind in the late 1600s and it was later
replaced by another description by
another brilliant human mind namely
albert einstein and that seems to pull
us back to the idea of description as
opposed to the math being out there
sylvia does either of those
ways of looking at math pull you in one
direction or another more toward it
being out there
versus invented or more toward the
reverse
i um certainly would also think that um
the
the success of mathematics in
application scientific applications
points towards mathematics being out
there mathematics being uh discovered
and so sometimes so the examples you
were just referring to it it looked to
me like um what was happening was that
we were eventually revising our physical
theories but if we're talking about
purely mathematical theorems
they are eternally true they don't once
they're approved they don't get revised
anymore
so i i think it's important to draw that
to draw that distinction
um and i think that applicability is
really one of the
most forceful arguments in favor of
what philosophers call mathematical
realism the view that mathematics is out
there um that mathematical objects exist
independently of human minds
but it's one thing for math to exist as
both you and shelly were referencing as
something that perhaps might be given
the label real
versus mathematics being out there
as
the reality that we can touch and feel
and interact with as opposed to
something that we're able to cogitate
about in some abstract sense
so i mean i'm going to be
straightforward about it i waffle
on this question i have changed my mind
over the course of my career between
whether math is invented or discovered
i almost can tie it to how
well my research is going when the
research is going really well it kind of
feels like all that i'm doing is like
discovering something that that's out
there it just is falling into place and
you feel it has to be out there because
it's locking together with such power
and such economy and
and it's so gratifying to see the
equations just really doing what they're
doing almost independently of of the
human who might be scribbling them out
on a piece of paper
at other times i've come to the reverse
where it just feels like we're just
trying to trying to push this
mathematical description on the external
world and sometimes it resists because
it's not
the the right language or the right
approach for actually describing
physical arousal so i go
back and forth on this but but you you
personally
do do do you come down on that issue
with one
uh unassailable and immutable view or or
do you also find it going back and forth
i'm pretty
i'm pretty certain that mathematics
is an objective um thing out there so
i've i've never felt very drawn to
fictionalist views of mathematics
um the notion of mathematical
fictionalism that really in some sense
what we've done is we've written this
wonderful rubric called mathematics
which is has proven itself capable of
describing the world but we couldn't
even describe the external reality
without already having that rubric to
begin with how would we even interpret
the motion of the moon if we didn't have
the mathematical language to talk about
it how would we talk about the motion of
particles if we didn't already have the
vocabulary that mathematics provides us
so
is that perhaps biasing our view
it
might be um though i think it
to be fair i think fictionalists about
mathematics are perfectly happy to say
that mathematics is
perhaps an indispensable tool or a very
important tool that we need to uh to do
empirical science
um
and
i think i just think that the the
fictionalist
stance the fictionalist philosophical
position
arises from
an unwillingness to um posit the
existence of abstract objects out there
so
much about much of the fiction in this
position is a reaction against
mathematical
uh realism or uh platonism even
and so i think um
fictionalists arguments have so far not
succeeded in convincing me that there is
something wrong with mathematical
realism
david earlier mentioned hartree field
he is famous for having managed to
nominalize newtonian gravitational
theory
which means that he managed to
reformulate the theory in a way that
doesn't refer at all to mathematical
objects or to mathematical entities it
doesn't use any mathematical language
anymore
and that's an incredible um achievement
and so that's more than just translating
a mathematical
sentence into an english sentence like
force equals g times m1 i mean all that
it's much more than that right than that
it's much more than that yeah there is a
like i said there is a sort of
fairly precise and and fairly compelling
once once you follow the arguments
criterion that quine wrote down
to diagnose whether this or that theory
that that you believe in
[Music]
is
treating this or that kind of object as
existent okay
and
and
field in what he was doing was
constrained by that okay and wanted to
show
that newtonian mechanics could be
formulated um the newtonian mechanics or
the gravitational part of newtonian
mechanics could be formulated in such a
way as
to
satisfy the condition that according to
quine's criterion of existence it didn't
count numbers as existing objects
and and so does did that
push you in a direction of thinking that
math is auxiliary
that math is displaceable
to the extent that you believe something
like that and to the extent that you
believe that it could be extended to to
all of natural science i might say that
hartreefield himself um recently is more
pessimistic about uh the possibility of
that project succeeding than he used to
be i was just bringing it up here
because
these questions do numbers really exist
so on and so forth i
it's
what's precious in these conversations
is to find some way to get beyond
people scratching their chins and
looking as if they're having profound
thoughts
and actually find
some criterion that you could get your
teeth into
and that you could do some work on
and claim to
have discovered the beginnings of
answers to these kinds of questions
maybe at the end of the day
this isn't going to pan out this isn't
going to be the right way to decide
which things exist and which don't and
there are going to be these intuitions
of the kind that shelley evoked
that this is something mysteriously
that we feel we know with a level of
certainty that we don't experience in
any other way and at the same time
it's not something that we can tell a
story as we can with neptune and with
reference to what max was saying i think
there's a big disanalogy between neptune
and and claims about the existence of
the number five um or something like
that we know how to tell a story about
how we know about the existence of
neptune it's a causal story okay um it
has to do with neptune's having
direct physical influences on a chain of
things that eventually ends up inside
our heads
in the case of mathematics we don't have
a story like that a causal story that
links
the existence of the number five to a
certain brain state
of mind so there's a real dilemma there
there are real powerful
intuitive forces pulling you in two
different um directions at the same time
and the thing that's and that's a
that's a tension
in which it's imaginable just to remain
forever
the thing that's refreshing about an
observation like kwines is it is it
might give you another direction um
another slightly different way of
raising these questions so max the
number five presumably it's never done
anything to you you've never felt the
number five you've never reacted the way
you would if a black hole were next to
you
what's that
well there you go so it has affected you
in some metaphysical way but but does
that description that david just gave
make you rethink it all the analogy with
neptune that you gave
i would put no i would push back
actually on this a bit i think the
reason that um
the business with
causality comes in and so much in your
in your arguments that you so eloquently
made there david is because you know
it's a causality only
makes sense even if once you have the
concept of time right first things are
like this
and then
that somehow causes things to be like
that at a later time
the mathematics in our universe is at a
much deeper level that even transcends
time if you come back and ask questions
about
the the things that mathematicians
ultimately really study in mathematical
structures
there isn't necessarily even any time
there like look at the cube
you know if you study the cube what
properties does it have it has
it has
six faces it has 12 edges
it has eight corners was the cube
created causally that
did the cube once have only five faces
and then no
the cube exists
completely outside of time and space as
well for that matter and when we when we
look at how
our physical
space is thought about in science
right einstein came along and said you
know
time we should think of just as the
fourth dimension of this timeless thing
called
space-time which is
and uh if if the reality they were
having this discussion in right now were
a movie
then space-time would be the entire dvd
right so uh what i'm saying here brian
and the answer to your question in
response to your question is
these mathematical structures that
mathematicians study
they don't exist
in time
or in space
but space and time exist inside of some
of them like inside of the
four-dimensional space-time
of einstein which mathematicians
refer to by the nerdy name of
minkowski space and five is just like
that
mathematicians don't just study five
they study this one mathematical object
called the integers
and five of them five is is
is part of that where the integers ever
created
there's no reference to time in there at
all and therefore there's no element of
causality in it it's in that sense that
i feel these mathematical structures
just exist and we're not obliged to
explain what caused them to pop into
existence because they never did
if i can jump in
the the causal story wasn't about
questions about how they got there
it came up in connection with questions
about how we know about them
we have a how information about them if
we're thinking of them as things outside
of our heads no less than tables and
chairs are outside of our heads okay
there's a question that arises about how
they got from their positions how
information about them got from outside
of our heads to inside of our heads okay
in the case of tables and chairs
we have a story about that how that
happens that story involves causation i
completely agree with you that causation
is already a higher level notion
it's based on mathematical ideas so on
and so forth nonetheless
once we have this causal language it
gives us a satisfying story about how we
found out about these tables and shares
there may also be a causal story about
how the tables and chairs got there but
that's not what we're concerned with at
the moment we're concerned with how we
found out about them i i think the cube
would still have six faces even if it
never got into our head you know if you
rewind five billion years ago and there
were no humans if there were some aliens
for some who built this some super
computer that started classifying
geometric objects
it it would still get the cube on the
list and the computer with calculator
has it's got six faces
and it has eight corners and twelve
edges
even if there were no heads at all in
existence in the in the universe at that
time and it's in that sense that i feel
that that mathematical structure it has
those properties
and data came along and we found out
about them but we didn't make it pop
into existence we just discovered its
existence
something that i think and of course
sylvia knows much much more about this
than i do
but something that i think has often
puzzled people about mathematical
knowledge is that that kind of an
account of how this stuff got into our
heads doesn't seem to be available in
that case
we cannot tell a story that is
convincing to us
by our by today's standards of how we
have epistemic access to these
mathematical objects that are
purportedly out there
um i just wanted to point out that um
plato of course had a story about it he
thought that our souls
before we came into existence before we
were born our souls were communing with
the eternal forms
and so during life where recollect
it's you know mathematical knowledge is
a recollection of that time but also
mathematicians like godel for example
thought that well
we have our five senses with which we
perceive physical objects but we also
have mathematical intuition he believed
that you know there is this mathematical
landscape out there
and we perceive it with an additional
sense perhaps we could call it our
mathematical sense
and he thought there was nothing you
know particularly perplexing about
telling such a story
i think it's just that nowadays we're
used to um
you know asking for
an empirical story an empirical
explanation for kinds of things that we
can or cannot know and that seems very
difficult in the case of mathematics the
reason we have trouble being satisfied
with how we come to know mathematics is
precisely because we know it so
intimately and so well
this would require a lot of elaboration
but um i really do think that's what's
going on it's a bit like consciousness
if we know something directly and
intimately maybe we shouldn't expect to
be able to give an account of how we
know it
an account of the kind which we feel so
satisfied about about for example
knowing that neptune was there we do the
analysis and we're so satisfied it comes
out right
but that's because we knew it indirectly
not intimately and that's true of so
much of physics you know we've had some
conversation about math describing the
external world that you know we can
touch and feel and observe and measure
and you just brought up consciousness
shelly which is the next section the
next chapter that i wanted to move into
which is
the paradigm of equality of the world
that we can't grasp in the way that we
can more familiar physical objects it's
something that as you say we have deep
knowledge of we have intimate connection
with and yet it's something that most
people i think intuitively would think
stands outside of mathematics not
something that can be described in that
particular language so is that enough to
really understand
consciousness or is consciousness
something
that is
much more perplexing than any of the
qualities of the world that we've been
talking about so far
here's what i tell my students i i
basically with regard to physics i'm
basically a pretty strong reductionist
so at the end of the day our simple like
hope will be at the end a simple t-shirt
equation which captures all the physics
we don't have anything like that yet
presumably but the equations we do have
are beautiful and they explain most of
what we say around it basically i say
that you know
the physics fundamental physics should
explain everything but then i tell my
students once and then
leave that out and forget that for the
rest of my of the course i tell them yes
but i lied to you consciousness is left
out physics does not explain everything
so you really think that consciousness
is left out uh will not absolutely i'm
i'm absolutely convinced of that why can
you i would
let me just say this is not a challenge
if you could convince me of that i would
be eternally grateful
because my view is is much more the
first view the reductionist view that
the end of the day were bags of
particles governed by physical law and
that's all there is to it it's a kind of
bleak but i think beautiful way of
looking at the world but tell me why i'm
wrong
look i couldn't convince look i had
exactly that view for many many years
i think sometime after i maybe after i
finished graduate school
i i suddenly
for me it was just an eye-opening
experience saying oh i was wrong all
these years i was so strongly arguing
against all these people who said no no
consciousness
can't be accounted for by
physics or mathematics i couldn't
understand why people were saying that
and suddenly
you know the phase transition can
occurred in my thinking and
do you remember what induced that phase
transition
yeah but i don't remember i know it was
reading
[Music]
vigner's remarks on the mind body
problem
but when i went back to look at it
later to see what was it precisely in
there that did the job for me i couldn't
see what it was so no i'm
to me it's not clear what it was but
certainly my thinking just changed
dramatically i mean i think david
chalmers does a great job in three or
four hundred pages of explaining
why it is that he thinks
that consciousness transcends physics
and mathematics
but
yeah you would like me to convince you
of it i mean i find this is the hardest
thing in the world to convince anybody
yeah yeah yeah
you can't remember an hour or two hours
three hours weeks maybe months can do it
of discussion it's maybe it's useful
just
to list
a couple of reasons that people do give
whether any of these reasons capture
what's going on with shelley there are
several different kinds of reasons that
people cite for being deeply puzzled
about how a reduction of consciousness
to physics would work somebody says to
me
[Music]
a bunch of particles arrayed like this
and moving in this way that's a table
okay and if i go back to them and i say
why is that a table there's a lot they
can say well look solve the equations of
motion you'll find that particles
assembled in this way will hold up
plates and glasses and you can be
convinced that the way we ourselves
recognize what a table is is by means of
its causal interactions with us and with
the rest of the world you can give a
very convincing story about why
an assembly of particles arranged in
that way moving in that way is a table
if you try to play the same game with
say the sensation of green or the
sensation of red okay there's a feeling
that somebody tells me the sensation of
green is a is a bunch of ions in your
head going this way and the sensation of
red is a bunch of ions in your head
going this way
it's just hard to see
why
why there's something
greener about this kind of motion and
redder about this kind of motion it
feels like it feels like a case of
comparing apples and oranges
you just don't know what to say you
don't see what they have to do with one
another you don't see what the
connection is and this is what what
shelley talked about in terms of the
intimacy of our acquaintance with these
things is relevant here
unlike identifying something as a table
or a chair or an orangutang or a
computer or anything like this plausibly
we pick out all of those things by means
of their causal effects on us
the sensation of redness doesn't seem
like that we don't distinguish red from
green
in terms of their different causal
effects on us we distinguish them from
one another somehow
just by the state of being in them
and conscious phenomenal states seem
like the only things in the world that
have that kind of
relationship to us so this is one reason
why people are
puzzled um i don't know if it's
shelley's reason
it's certainly certainly there are other
ones people cite
suppose i say of myself
i'm just a machine i'm just a collection
of billiard balls bouncing around like
this
and somebody says why do you believe
that
you say i think i have good reasons for
believing that our scientific
investigations of the world suggest that
something like that is true
and the guy says gee i'm puzzled
you just claimed
that
you're the kind of
physical system
whose properties including your beliefs
are just determined by the physical laws
okay
um
but now you're acting as if there's
something else that goes into
determining your beliefs some kind of
sensitivity to what's reasonable but if
your model of yourself
is is the correct one that model denies
that there is any kind of additional
sensitivity to reasons if somebody asked
me why i believe that two plus two is
four
i have the feeling
that i can see how
it couldn't not be the case that two
plus two is for this is the kind of
certainty that shelley refers to but if
i really take it seriously that
everything about me is just covered by
the initial conditions and the laws of
physics then there's only one
explanation available of why i believe
that two plus two is four that's because
of the initial conditions of the world
and uh
and the laws of physics okay and there's
nothing about the truth that enters into
the explanation of my belief that two
plus two is four so i would like to
inject some optimism here
both to david who was worried that uh
his bouncing particles couldn't really
be trusted in their views about the
outside world and to you shelley who are
worried that consciousness can forever
be on physics and reductionism and also
to you brian who
was using the word
bleak to describe reductionism so if we
start with you david i think that
the reason you should actually put some
trust into what your bouncing
quarks and electrons
are having you tell us about the state
of the world is because
as brian said there is this additional
story you can
add on top of it the super beans on on
just particle physics
it just follows from it and it's the
story of darwinian evolution
we obviously there were probably a lot
of organisms who were really really
lousy at taking information from the
environment and coming up with correct
predictions and they got eaten or
starved to death and those who were
still around
have evolved
to actually
tend to have more reasonable beliefs
mostly about what's going on
just to i just want to
get the shelley first also so for the
for the
this notion that we're forever doomed to
never be able to explain consciousness i
think
history actually gives a lot of hope
here
so brian mentioned galileo before if if
galileo threw a grape and a hazelnut
right he could predict wonderfully how
they would both move in a parabola and
when they would hit the ground but he
had no clue why the grape was green and
soft
and the hazelnut was brown and hard
and that really seemed the most
scientist at the time to be just beyond
physics how could he ever predict that
it was going to be green
but then
maxwell's equations came along and
showed that colors and light can be
described by mathematics
the schroedinger equation of quantum
mechanics was discovered and helped us
calculate why the hazelnut is hard and
and the grape is soft
and gradually physics went from this
situation where it could describe almost
nothing except motion
of the phenomena in the world right to
where we are today where it can describe
almost everything
and
from the subatomic world you know to our
expanding universe and the formation of
black holes and interestingly what's
left
the final biggest bastion of ignorance
that we have to try to conquer our
intelligence and consciousness which is
exactly where we we're going in now and
um
we will come back and talk about this
later but
my guess is that
both intelligence and consciousness are
particular kinds of information
processing that we can ultimately also
describe with math
and in fact that's the reason why ai has
been so successful recently and
making some progress on on the
intelligence side
and there are mathematical theories by
giulio tinoni and others also what they
try to do with consciences
but i agree we should be humble we're
absolutely not there yet but we should
we should be optimistic that there's
hope and last brian uh you you said it
felt bleak
to acknowledge that
you're just a blob of of quarks and
electrons evolving according to the
standard model of particle physics
i object to you so i shouldn't say
spoken many people see it as bleak my
own view is it's spectacular that
particles and bags and collections of
products do the things that we do so my
view is actually quite the opposite but
i don't know where you come down on it
so uh
richard feynman who's inspired me
enormously has this very beautiful uh
counter-argument to this
you know he was arguing with an artist
who said that euphysis just ruined
everything by trying to describe it
reductionistically
you hold up a flower and say look how
beautiful it is but you as a scientist
all take this all apart and it becomes
dull thin
first of all
i can't appreciate the beauty of a
flower
at the same time i see much more about
the flower than he sees i could imagine
the cells in there the complicated
actions inside which also have a beauty
i mean it's not just beauty at this
dimension of one centimeter there's also
beauty in the smaller dimensions
the inner structure also the processes
the fact that
the colors and the flower evolved
in order to attract insects to pollinate
it all kinds of interesting questions
which the science
knowledge only adds to the
excitement the mystery and the awe of a
flower it only adds i don't understand
how it subtracts the feynman rose story
is a beautiful one that i've recounted
many times too so i i totally agree with
that perspective sylvia
i just want to turn to you on this
question of of
the
self-reflective inner awareness that we
human beings have within our heads
do you see that as part of a
mathematical description of the world or
for instance would you imagine that
other languages or other perspectives
need to be brought in to have a full
understanding of that quality of the
world
i sometimes feel that
the puzzlement about consciousness and
what we can achieve with mathematical
descriptions of consciousness
arise partly from
different
meanings that the word description has
so um we can think of all kinds of
descriptions descriptions in different
languages
so if we think of conscious conscious
experience we could think of
trying to find a mathematical
description of that and that would help
us understand
um for example what distinguishes uh
conscious beings from unconscious
objects in the world
um and so what we
the goal of such a description would be
to enlighten us on the physics
underlying conscious experience
but we could have a totally different
goal for our description for example
to
replicate or to induce a particular
phenomenal experience in another being
that we're trying to describe our
conscious experience to
and in order to achieve that goal
um a different kind of description might
be much more suitable so let's say
if you had never in your life tasted
vanilla ice cream
and i was going to try to describe to
you
what it
what it tastes like
then
perhaps a mathematical description would
not be the best one or let's think about
a different example ice cream is a
little bit too too trivial think about
the emotion of fear
um
i could give a mathematical explanation
of what happens in a subject's brain
when that subject is in a state of fear
i could describe you know which neurons
are firing and what exactly has happened
on the on the particle level in that
person's organism
but in order to make you understand
assuming that you're a being who's never
had um who's never felt fear
in order to explain to you
what fear is like
it might be more useful to use a
completely different kind of description
using a different kind of language let's
say the language of music
um it's famously and this also relates
um to what we just heard about you know
uh disputes between physicists and
artists famously art can reveal and
communicate let's say knowledge can
communicate things can reveal things to
us
that cannot be revealed in a different
in a different way using a different
language
so i think we always have to ask what
exactly is it that we want to achieve
with a particular description
and if what we want to achieve is to get
a better sense in terms of the
underlying physics of consciousness then
my intuition is more on on max's side i
think we can be hopeful that
empirical science will at some point
uh be able to figure out a mathematical
model for consciousness
if it's about
making another
sentient being understand what my inner
life is like
i'm much more skeptical what about
morality just turning the gears a little
bit further human minds human brains are
are able
to have a moral sensibility of right and
wrong and good and evil and all those
qualities that are so vital to
a rich life here on planet earth
do does morality and those notions do
they stand in your view
outside
of the mathematical description or the
mathematical universe or are they
subsumed within it in some deep way that
might not be the most efficient or
effective way of describing them but
nevertheless they are accounted for in a
mathematical way of thinking about the
world
i think mathematics um
gives us an interesting
paradigm or an interesting model um that
can help us to try and understand how
morality fits into our empirical world
so we've discussed this earlier in the
program that you know people are
some people are drawn to the idea that
there exist mathematical objects other
people object to that idea and think
that's completely crazy because those
objects would be so vastly different
from the objects we're familiar with
physical objects
and pretty much the same thing can be
said about moral entities you know like
um
moral values for example would be what i
call a moral object
and so
there are some people out there
let's call them moral realists who
believe that morality is something
much like mathematics it's it's eternal
there are eternal truths out there and
what we're trying to do when we think
about morality is to sort of
um
dock onto those truths like to capture
those truths and um
represent them in our beliefs but that
of course entails that moral objects
exist and it's
very confusing uh to some people to to
to imagine what that would look like
i think that thinking about mathematics
and seeing that we have good reason to
believe in mathematical realism and we
shouldn't be afraid of positing those
entities can actually help us overcome
our scruples also in the moral arena
so one one
uh one of the main arguments that is
usually
cited in favor of moral anti-realism in
favor of the view that morality is is
something invented something that we
constructed for some evolutionary
purpose one of the main arguments is
always disagreement
we vastly or human beings vastly
disagree on what are the moral truths
therefore there cannot be any
substantial truths out there
now i think
there are a number of reasons why that
argument is
is flawed but
um the com the the comparison to
mathematics can lend credibility to the
view of moral realism and here is the
comparison
if the reason to reject realism about
morality is
fundamental disagreement
we have the same also in the
mathematical arena it's true that
mathematics is often viewed as this sort
of disagreement-free
cosmos where
all that mathematicians are doing is
discover new mathematical theorems or
prove new mathematical theorems but in
fact when when we look at the
foundations of mathematics of set set
theory for example
we can see that there is pretty vast
disagreement on pretty fundamental
questions also in mathematics for
example on the question how many
mathematical universes are there
and so i think that this this main
argument against moral and
against moral realism
can be discarded once we turn
to mathematics so that's just one way in
which the analogy between mathematics
and morality can be enlightening
well i'm not all that comfortable with
the
plurality of mathematical truths in the
sense that genuinely conflicting
mathematical truths i
that's something i have trouble
understanding
um
i do think the analogy between
mathematics and morality is a useful one
just as justice sylvia said
and of course the big difference is that
i at least for most people and that's i
think well i don't know about most
people for me in any case
um mathematical truths
force themselves on me with a
con compulsion which is
at least somewhat lacking when it comes
to
moral truths i'm not a moral relative a
moral realist but um
nonetheless uh the mathematical realism
that just seemed to
that i that i thought i feel much more
strongly maybe a distinction however is
relevant
not sure it's a sensible one or not with
a distinction which would apply both to
mathematicals mathematical reality and
moral reality and that the distinction
is this
what is mathematical realism what is
moral realism
in both cases you might say you might
say the mathematical realism you believe
in the objectivity
of mathematical propositions or moral
truths
you believe for example somehow that
there there really is it's not there are
an infinite number of primes and there
always were and you did there didn't
have to be people around for that to be
true there simply are an infinite number
of primes
that's certainly a view that a
mathematical realist would have
now
for many mathematical realists if not
most and many would david might say how
will you how would you maybe you're
forced to have this view but i know many
people would say but i do not want to
insist that there are mathematical
objects somehow i i don't believe
there's a separate realm of mathematical
objects there's a realm of mathematical
truth i can certainly say that somehow
or other there's definitely an infinite
number of primes but i don't believe
prime numbers exist the mathematical
objects themselves don't exist i think
that's a view some people have
david any uh
any thoughts on the morality uh math
analogy there's an argument that
mathematics is indispensable
mathematical some kind of mathematical
realism is indispensable to the
scientific project and i take it there's
no analogous argument in the moral case
we can teach people a whole course of
theoretical physics without mentioning
the words good or bad um but we can't do
it without without mentioning the word
five right right can i just
that yeah yes
judge our ontological commitments to
mathematical entities with reference to
the scientific project and that's
because the scientific project seems
like
um
[Music]
itself like an intrinsically
indispensable project that science is
our paradigm for knowledge at the moment
but here is an alternative
indispensability argument for
moral entities
or a criterion as david called it
if we
cannot
not quantify over um moral entities or
normative entities in a project of our
lives that is intrinsic intrinsically
indispensable perhaps not science but
something else then that might also give
us a reason
to believe in the existence of uh moral
entities and so it has been argued this
is not my argument this is
david enoch's argument
it has been argued that
quantifying or referring to normative
entities like reasons or values is
indispensable to the intrinsically
indispensable project of deliberation
human beings cannot fail to deliberate
we deliberate all the time in order to
come up with uh well in order to decide
how to behave and how to interact with
the world
and in this indispensable project of
deliberation we cannot fail to refer to
normative entities and so
that's a sort of analogous
indispensability argument that i think
has definitely some force
this question is actually incredibly
timely because
we're now putting
rather mathematical based objects
artificial intelligence right in charge
of ever more decisions they're out there
now deciding who gets a loan who does
not get a loan they're having influence
of who gets probation who stays in jail
very controversially some people are
even
wanting to build weapons that themselves
decide who lives and who dies right and
and
then this question of
sort of splits into two parts one is how
can you actually mathematically codify
an ethical moral system so that you can
explain it to a machine
a self-driving car or or whatever
there's and this is a booming field now
in machine learning
machine ethics and then the separate
question is well okay if you can
quantify mathematically all these
different
systems of morality well which one is
the best
uh
this one clearly there's no consensus on
but i want to inject just a little bit
of optimism here too because frankly
i don't think the reason our world is in
such dire straits right now is because
we can't find we haven't managed to
answer exactly that question
almost everybody on this planet agrees
that hey it's better if humanity does
not go extinct than if we do go extinct
uh it's better to have less poverty than
to have more poverty so the reason we as
a species are still epically failing at
avoiding you know the risk of nuclear
war and avoiding people
starving to death all the time
isn't because
of this moral disagreement it's it's
more about the
for some reason
we just really haven't gotten our act
together
and having and
in the way we manage our planet and
people often
push in a certain direction because they
think it's gonna be in a way they think
is morally good and and it isn't so i
think i think
uh
the optimistic part is i don't think
we're limited by our understanding of
math and morality and our opportunity to
make a better future
so with that optimistic note i want to
turn to uh the final section
max one of the ideas that you are a
proponent of in terms of discussion
we've had a little bit around a corner
where
we've been discussing sort of the
universe and math either as a
description of it or somehow being part
of it or somehow being you know
deeply connected with
physical reality you go further and
suggest that perhaps we should turn that
question around and view math
as the real reality which every so often
perhaps looks like the physical reality
that we experience but but it's the real
uber you know bottom line most basic
reality that exists i don't know if i'm
describing that accurately but if you
could give us you know your sense of of
this view of mathematics and then we can
have some of the folks weigh in as to
whether that's a view that that
resonates with them or not
that's right so if you look at the
spectrum of views you can have from it's
all in our heads you know all just
invented to
somehow it's in some sense out there i'm
as far as you can go i think on the
opposite extreme
saying not only does mathematics
describe our universe but our universe
is
actually mathematical in the sense that
we live in a gigantic mathematical
object and
when you first hear that
frankly it sounds ridiculous it sounds
absurd right if you all look around in
the room you're sitting right now
if this is all supposed to be
mathematical well i mean
where is the math you know
i i'm looking around in my room outside
my window now i see a tree here you know
if something is entirely mathematical it
means
that
all its properties are mathematical
properties it has only mathematical
properties but that tree there it's
green and brown and it's leafy you know
that doesn't sound
like mathematical properties at all so
what am i even talking about well when i
look at the tree again though
through my eyes as a physicist
i see a blob of quarks and electrons and
what are the properties of an electron
minus one
one half
one and of course we physicists have
made up nerdy names for those properties
like electric charge
spin and lepton numbers but that was
just the language we made up to refer to
those numbers the properties are just
numbers and and you brian know as well
as anybody that the only difference
between an electron and an up quark is
what numbers
its properties are and then
what about so if all the stuff
in our space
has only mathematical properties then
what about the space itself what
properties does space have well if
it has the property three for example
that's the largest number of fingers i
can put that are perpendicular to each
other
again we made up a
fancy name for that we call it the
dimensionality of the space
but that word is just the word we made
up like the word neptune the property of
space is three
and then we heard earlier you the
non-euclidean geometry came up
we now know that space also has
properties of curvature and topology
which you study in in graduate math
classes they're entirely mathematical
properties so if you accept the idea
that all the stuff in space as well as
space itself
actually seems as far as we can tell as
physicists have no properties at all
except mathematical properties then it
starts to sound a little bit less
insane
that
maybe our entire physical reality is in
fact a mathematical object
max
is your view com is your view compatible
with the view that which you don't
presumably don't have but is it
compatible with the view that
consciousness transcends mathematics and
physics
i
would guess
that consciousness
and intelligence are certain kinds of
information processing uh not all kinds
of information processing but the one
day someone will discover an equation
and maybe julia tinoni already has it
such that when the information
processing obeys that there is a
subjective experience there like david
albert so
eloquently um described um and
information itself of course as we
learned from claude shannon is shouldn't
be described entirely mathematically as
well
so by max along the lines of the you
know the the minus one and the half you
know in terms of electric charge and
spin and so forth of course i totally
understand where you're coming from and
yes if you were to ask me what is an
electron like what really is it
i would ultimately be forced to give the
description that you are rehearsing you
know i'd give you its charge as a number
i'd give you a spin and i wouldn't be
able to talk about electron-ness in any
other more fundamental less mathematical
way but but that still could be a human
description of the electron as opposed
to
the real intrinsic
electron-ness of that particle right it
could still be us humans imposing a
description
we developed this tool and it does a
good job a great job but it could still
be that no
it's really fascinating i think
historically and i'm so grateful
sylvia for you giving us this this
historical perspective how
again and again uh if you took just
traditional materialism saying oh
there's this stuff as if we knew what
that really was right how
all the non-mathematical properties we
used to talk about one by one have just
sort of melted away and we just seem to
be left with only the mathematical ones
uh
even the fact that there is a particle
there an electron we know now of course
is also an oversimplification there is
this thing called a quantum field
and
how many electrons are in there it just
tells you something about that state in
the field it's like how much the guitar
string is vibrating how excited is some
mode of this um entirely mathematical
right and then came quantum mechanics
and said well actually you describe the
whole thing with a wave function that
lives in this place called the hilbert
space completely mathematical things
and i i think i i find it very
intriguing that throughout the history
of physics
whenever we have found that some
mathematical description of the world
was inadequate it wasn't quite right
and we had a revolution and replaced it
by something else that something else
was also mathematical
and the most ambitious attempt so far to
find a single set of equations you can
put on a t-shirt maybe in the future
string theory as you know better than
anyone else on this
here on this this panel brian
is entirely mathematical too i really
don't see any evidence so far from
nature
that there's anything non-mathematical
about the world now if i understand you
go much further than what you've so far
recounted you would actually go so far
as to say that all
of mathematics is as real or i should
say any piece of mathematics is as real
as any other piece of math you don't
distinguish between
math that's relevant to reality and
method isn't relevant is that is that an
accurate description that's right they
sometimes call that the level four
multiverse so when we talk about
something existing if we say that pink
elephants don't exist
what we secretly tend to mean by that is
why they don't exist here on earth or
anywhere where we've looked
um but maybe there's another planet
really really far away whether you
actually have pink elephants somewhere
else
right
and um
we've gone through this progression in
history where again and again and again
we've come to realize
that the totality of physical reality
that exists is just way bigger than we
thought then everything we knew about is
just a small part of something grander a
planet you know solar system a galaxy a
galaxy cluster
our observable universe
it's probably much bigger than the part
that we can see that light has reached
us from etc and
if what i'm saying what i'm guessing is
true then it's bigger still so you have
all of these different mathematical
structures that mathematicians like
shelley can study
the cube a columbia manifold you know
minkowski space
three plus one dimensional
manifold the
hilbert space etc
if they're you know hilbert the
mathematician who was quoted earlier
famously said that mathematical
existence is just a freedom from
contradiction there are a lot of
different objects that exist
mathematically and my guess is that we
inhabit one of them
and if there are other ones which are
also complicated enough that some of
their inhabitants are conscious and have
experiences they're gonna feel that
their
exists physically and just the same as
we feel that ours exists physically and
in just a sense the same sense that if
you brian were actually right now in a
some future very high tech computer game
you know this governed by mathematical
laws you know you wouldn't feel any
different you would feel of course my my
little game world here exists and i can
punch the table it'll punch me back um
so yes if this is true i think
this uh copernican revolution needs to
go one step farther and and there is the
ultimate reality is still much bigger
than we thought david any any thoughts
on whether we might be living in sort of
the the mathematical reality of all
equations being instantiated in some way
shape or form
i mean
first of all they don't
i
all i'm going to be able to express
about this is a certain kind of
bafflement um about what's going on and
how i'm supposed to understand it i mean
when
um max when you say
um our description of the world has
gotten more and more
mathematical more and more of the
non-mathematical things have been
eliminated i'm not sure i understand
what that means you talk about you know
plato and aristotle sitting around or
cavemen sitting around
the the nobody would have doubted that
the tree that they're looking at has
some volume okay and you can assign a
number to that okay um what number you
design is gonna is a sign is gonna
depend of course on your choice of units
and that's no less true for the electron
spin um um than it is for the people
sitting around looking at a tree but do
we think they would have denied that the
tree has a volume do we think they would
have denied that the tree has a
mathematical description it's just that
you seem to want to collapse
um
any distinction between the mathematical
description of these things and the
things being mathematically
described and there i just really get
confused it's as if you know if somebody
comes up to me and tells me
all of these perplexities that you're
having are going to evaporate if you can
just get it into your head
that
a cucumber is really a ferrari okay
and and if you can just get your head
around that everything's going to be
fine and i sit there saying cucumber
ferrari cucumber all i have to do is
figure out how to see that a cucumber is
really a ferrari i can't do it i don't
know what i'm being asked i don't know
what i'm being asked to imagine and i
don't know what i'm being asked to
imagine when somebody tells me no it's
not just
that the tree has a volume that can be
expressed by a number it's that the tree
is
the number um like i say i'm just being
thick-headed here uh i'm just being
stupid i don't understand what it is
that i'm asked to being asked to imagine
so it's a it's a it's a fair question
but i think it's one that has a good
answer there is something that's really
fundamentally changed in our
understanding of trees in the past
thousands of years
in the beginning when archimedes was
studying trees and galileo was studying
trees there were some very limited
aspects of the of the properties of the
tree that they could describe
mathematically they could describe how
long it would take for a branch to fall
down if it fell off and stuff like that
but they had no idea why the wood was so
rigid and stiff and why the bark looked
brown and so on
there were measurements you could make
of the tree that you just had no
mathematical way of calculating the
answer to that's just really changed
today
we really there are still
there are there's no evidence i would
say that there is that
you couldn't if you were to sufficiently
if you were to
that you couldn't at least in principle
derive all properties of a tree from the
standard model of particle physics we
know in math
just because you have the fundamental
equations does not mean you can always
calculate things accurately you know we
can't even calculate the mass of the
proton relative to the neutron
accurately even though we really think
we know
gladys qcd right um
we're in computing exactly how the tree
is gonna grow up just from knowing its
dna you know right now it's beyond our
ability to compute but i would say
there's the evidence that there's
something more to the tree than a quark
blob
has sort of melted away that
that's not true of all of physics uh
consciousness and intelligence
especially consciousness i think we have
to be very open-minded that maybe we're
missing something big but certainly
with with trees i think
uh there's every reason to believe that
we've got the fundamental description of
it
right and it's mathematical and now
we're struggling with
how we can link that to the sort of
higher level uh processes that are going
on of a growing living
max if i can just push back a little bit
look
everybody would have agreed thousands of
years ago that trees have tiny little
pieces okay
and that trees are in some sense the sum
of their tiny little pieces okay
um um and probably they would have
agreed that the pieces are in some sense
simpler than than the whole tree itself
still
i don't understand how that takes us one
inch in the direction of saying
something like the tree just is
numbers um
we
we're getting better and better at not
only describing the tree using numbers
but predicting how the tree is going to
behave in a way
that that um that in a limitably makes
use of numbers okay but if somebody says
um
here you got two apples here um
[Music]
so
i don't know what the next move is to be
is supposed to be so really all you have
here is the number two if you really
think of it i i it it really feels like
cucumbers and ferraris i don't want to
talk smack about cavemen or physicists
from 2000 years ago but they did not
understand that trees are made of air
primarily that they actually take carbon
dioxide out of this out of this the air
and sunlight they take energy to bind it
in and and and so on uh these are new
things they were just missing they
didn't have a complete understanding of
of the makeup of trees
that we now do right and
whereas now i think we're at the point
where there really is no evidence that
trees are made of a new kind of quark
that hasn't yet been discovered or that
you have to overthrow string theory to
describe trees
the second point that you raise which is
also very important is i think
the distinction between saying that
something is described by math and
saying that it is mathematical and that
might be related to your cucumber
ferrari issue so right in mathematics
there's a very beautiful uh
body at work on on equivalence there are
many different ways in which you can
mathematically
describe
for example the integers piano wrote
down five axioms and the certain
descriptions you can you can start in
many different places you can use
different symbols different notation
and when we talk about a mathematical
structure
what we actually mean isn't any one
description of it but we mean the
equivalence class of that thing which is
described by all the equivalent
descriptions that's the thing that
exists so there isn't in the in in
plato's mathematical
realm
to different cubes
that there is just one mathematical
structure of the cube right and in the
same way if it turns out our physical
world
if you if you think of a mathematical
structure just a bunch of abstract
elements with relations between them if
that corresponds one-to-one
with
the abstract element with with elements
in that we call physical things
like super strings or quarks or whatever
and relations between them
and you just have basically two
different descriptions of the same
structure then
they are one and the same thing and it's
that in that sense that i say that our
physical i think our physical world
really is a mathematical structure you
know you could even write a computer
program that starts to just classify
one by one different structures that
exist in mathematics
my guess is that
there is a mathematical structure which
is in fact the one that we live in
and since we live in it we have come up
with also the human words to refer to
the entities we talk about we call them
electrons and quarks or whatever
but they are just the names that we
humans have come up with
for referring to
abstract mathematical entities well i've
certainly enjoyed our conversation with
all of you mathematical objects if you
allow me to use that language clearly
this is an argument that could keep on
going for some time and it's a sharper
version of the very question we began
with in terms of is math a description
is math a human invention is math
actually out there or in max's vision is
math the be-all and end-all of reality
wherever we come down on questions like
that i think all of us here and
hopefully everyone who's watching this
can get a sense of how beautiful
mathematics is how powerful it is at
describing the world perhaps it's even
more than that i began with
some quotes at the beginning of our
conversation i want to end with a few
quotes that capture that spirit first
from bertrand russell
mathematics rightly viewed possesses not
only truth but supreme beauty a beauty
cold and austere like that of a
sculpture without appeal to any part of
our weaker nature without the gorgeous
trappings of painting or music yet
sublimely pure and capable of a stern
perfection such as only the greatest art
can show
mariam murzakani said you have to spend
some energy and effort but if you do you
can see the beauty of mathematics
from g.h hardy
the mathematician's patterns like the
painters or the poets
must be beautiful the ideas like the
colors or the words must fit together in
a harmonious way
beauty is the first test there is no
permanent place in the world
for ugly mathematics and finally paul
erdos
why are numbers beautiful
it's like asking
why is beethoven's ninth symphony
beautiful
if you don't see why
someone can't tell you
i know numbers are beautiful
if they aren't beautiful
nothing is so with that let me just
thank all of you for this
wide-ranging conversation on math and
reality thanks so much for joining us
enjoy the conversation and maybe we'll
have the pleasure of picking up these
controversies sometime in the future
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
you